welcome to the internet have a look
around
don't get me started we can't we can't
get to it to there can't get copyright
claims even he'll do that by our
favorite
youtuber guys apparently they changed
some crap in one division the post
credits scene
they re-edited it no yeah that's what
they do now that's messed up now that
it's all in this one app
we can do whatever we want it's really
because we can really go back and
course correct but we just go to their
reality to go and fuss and never let
things be done it happens on spotify all
the time
let's see what happens i i don't know
the specifics i know it's
like at the very last say i think it's a
post credit scene right so we're gonna
watch eric voss's breakdown of it
the king that's where i got the shirt
from oh perfect boss's mom
um for me she admitted herself of love
in every stitch
[Music]
welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division's finale
post-credits scene was
altered apparently by disney plus with
quite a few
unexplained and kind of creepy visual
changes that were not in the original
cut of this episode
when it was uploaded to the disney plus
platform on march 5th among these
alterations is what many believe to be a
mysterious spectral forum gliding down
the hillside toward wanda maximoff's
cabin
is this doctor strange as many of us
have theorized
who noticed that which i know research
project
or is it a glorified lens flare or
smudge that youtube psychos like me are
making too much out of to try to justify
your magical thinking
to trust me that was my gut instinct too
the mepisto bullies have scarred me with
crippling self-awareness
this much still believe it the frame
was not in the original march 5th
version of the episode this was
added sometime recently also it's not
the only change to this footage
bfx artists for some reason added
several trees around the cabin
and removed a few beers that were
splashing around in the lake but perhaps
so the episode a credit for composer
michael chiquino for the use of his
dr strange theme which i previously
pointed out when the episode came out
has been audible over the shot of
wanda's astral projection with the dark
hole
wow are you telling me you even
like looked at every credit to make sure
yeah at this point you have to that's
what it takes to be the breakdown king
this is detected at the very end every
recording of
every version of every episode you ever
watched
i'm still in major skepticism i mean
okay the trees are way more the
multiverse
the trees and the birds are way more
noticeable than that look like it may be
as much but the fact that they
specifically altered
trees and birds that makes me go okay
let's hear what this
lens flare smudge looking thing possibly
can be
yeah i was kind of rolling my eyes
internally until i was like oh they
really did change stuff
that was gonna be it now marvel did not
have to do this they could have just
credited jaquino's mcu music
contributions
in general since the opening fanfare
that we've heard behind every marvel
studios title since 2016 including
episodes of one division was
originally composed by michael jacquino
as part of his work for the doctor
strange film but marvel went
out of their way to acknowledge his work
for the doctor strange theme
telling us that the overall purpose of
this re-edit
might have been to better link this
finale and its post-credits scene to the
doctor strange
films really the additional
post-production work on this particular
scene
might have been part of the
post-production on doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
which or at least reuse this footage as
part of a new scene
in that film yeah kevin feige himself
acknowledged that one division's finale
led to
rewrites for multiverse of madness and
that a doctor strange cameo was
initially planned for the one division
finale but was removed
part of that plan was to reveal the
in-universe commercials
were actually messages to wanda from
doctor strange
another was to feature doctor strange as
a ghostly blink and you'll miss it cameo
in the pharmacy for just one frame like
brad pitt in fight club but even before
all that would be cool when we first saw
that scene
showing wanda using astral projection a
spell used by doctor strange and other
sorcerers
while the doctor strange music was
playing in an episode where ek the
harkness read from this darkhold spell
book that the scarlet witch's powers
surpassed those of the sorcerer supreme
aka steven strange
with camera work that swoops in without
cutting into this cabin an homage to
sam raimi's shot in evil dead with
raymie directing multiverse of madness
dr strange's coming conflict with wanda
in multiverse of madness has
always been the subtext of this scene so
much so that my interpretation of it was
that this was shot from strange's point
of view as his astral form swooped down
into this cabin to confront wanda in
this moment and that's why she looked up
suddenly before we cut to black
so now in this floating ghostly shape
now appears in this one division
post-credits scene whenever you go on
disney plus
again after nothing was there in the
original upload
this starts to look at least a bit less
batshit
but here's what the blur is exactly
notice that windowed one is left as she
turns to go in the door
well in the original version a light
shined off it or through it maybe a
reflection of the crew
i don't know i think it's barely
noticeable honestly but the vfx artist
decided to mask it out and then an
artifact of that mask was left in that
exact point in the frame
and since this is all part of one
tracking shot that just kind of stands
in that frame from the moment we cross
dissolve into this angle making it look
like something because it changes in
color
quality to break any hearts hoping that
this could have been dr strange or
special vision
damn that is hilarious that's awesome
respect we got dead pixels an army of
the dead and we've got a leftover mask
in one division
i saw on social media we're talking
about they changed the post-credits
scene i think that's dr strange in there
i'm gonna wait for a certain new rock
star to put out a video and then we'll
go into it so i think it's hysterical
let's see what we want to see we see
what we want to see
but why did they change anything i have
no idea especially if it's like let's
take out some birds and add trees unless
they
really are just having fun with the
multiverse i mean i don't know i'm sure
that these all get tweaked in some
degree if this is a shot from doctor
strange maybe they're like you know this
needs to look even more
woodland maybe that is the case because
maybe this scene will be in doctor
strange so they retweeted it to be in
the actual movie so to link it up maybe
uh sam raimi was like i have a very
specific vision any more trees i have
this very specific kind of forest cabin
setting
birds out of here no birds is one doctor
strange this is not on my watch it still
could be doctor strange going in there
absolutely i mean i like eric's theory
that we're seeing from his sort of pov
on that but the smudge seems to be
the lens flare thing seems to be the
biggest takeaway out of all this like an
apparition of sorts or him and his
astral plane floating towards
her at all to come find out it's just
some vfx error which is what it just
looked like when we
first saw it into this video you know
you can make it you can believe whatever
you want still it
still works but the fact remains that
marvel vfx editor still went in to
spruce up this footage with other
changes that were clearly intentional
and that is still really weird and
uncommon and assuming that these
alterations were
intentional for marvel to have any
reason to reopen the one division
project file and tinker with it like
this
upload a new version hope no one notices
really the simplest explanation is that
marvel needed it to be done for some
upcoming project
meaning this could now be part of a
sequence in doctor strange and
multi-person
elizabeth olsen stated that wanda will
soon be held accountable for trapping
the citizens of west view in hex
we could be seeing that reckoning here
in the cabin and that scene in
multiverse of madness could take place
immediately after one division
coming out with rwanda in a kind of
sorcerer battle
with astral steven strange and perhaps
these trees were added because when
the extended version of this cabin
sequence was shot by sam raimi for
multiverse of madness that fight takes
place
among this new setting that they shot it
in that just happened to have more trees
and branches so
to better dovetail it with what we saw
in one division they need to go back and
add some trees to be around that cabin
why do the water birds need to be
removed well maybe some of the spells
cast in this wizard will kill
any living creature in the area or maybe
wanda now reveals that she created this
mountain refuge to prevent any other
living creature from entering that
bubble including wild animals
similar to how in the west you hex any
physical thing that
entered that bubble was either blocked
out or warped
i think they just removed the birds i
think yeah they just did some color
correction and they were like you know
what why not i never liked these birds
anyway they weren't supposed to be there
on the day i think it makes it feel a
little bit more warm and serene
when there's birds in there and she it's
she's more isolated
which is when there's no birds there it
enhances the natural world
feeling yeah or baby doctor strange's
power eliminates all animal living life
then it comes in its crap
dr strange is not vegan and now in the
new logic of the scene it just wouldn't
make sense for outside ducks to be
splashing around nearby
all i know is that i am now gonna have
to go back through all the wano vision
scenes to see if anything else has been
changed
nice going disney plus you just boosted
your streaming numbers with the
post-production equivalent of that high
school prank where you release chickens
and number them one two three and five
just
with the teachers but you can support
our madness here at new rock stars by
checking out our merch options including
our loki inspired shirt
oh you'll be seeing me where that's so
often follow me on instagram and twitter
at ea boss follow and subscribe to
directors thanks for watching
bye bye all right
well it's definitely doctor strange
which is so funny to me it's the ducks
they moved the ducks
i don't know who first discovered these
changes but it seems like the changes
were really first discovered
from the visual effects little glitch
air not even the trees and the birds
it seems to have been that little tiny
speck that just drove everyone bananas
was that one thing and some poor visual
effects artist is going
no the tree i worked so hard
make them look real no one's really
talking about some mistake
i got in trouble for this but if that
mistake wasn't there
people maybe might not not be talking no
not at all
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below do you think it was just a
mistake why do you think the birds are
eliminated
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
and uh subscribe to new rockstars ea vos
e a king